chassez le naturel il revient au galop
cela est vrai aussi aujourd'hui pour
l'alimentation comme le prouve le
développement des épiceries diététique
et biologique il y en a 25 à lyon ou
encore le succès des restaurants
macrobiotique 12 l'artificiel et
explique problème sans curé de tamari
financer de curcuma une intention de
tailler une place au safran non pas du
tout
la gagnante
personnellement elle ne manque pas on la
remplace par des céréales
par des produits
cocktail que le fromage les oeufs le
lait préparation passer le tout au
mixeur en commençant par les fruits puis
le tamari lorsque le mélange se fait
bien incorporer successivement les
aromates
et n'aura pas
essilor
alors
dans notre clientèle nous avons trois
quarts de gens qui ne sont pas
végétariens donc c'est quand même une
preuve que l'action végétarienne et
qu'elle est goûteuse puis les guides de
grenoux c'est bon c'est bon
pis les cuisses de grenouilles jusqu'au
ras du cou une suggestion de menus sous
votre réveillon de la saint sylvestre
avocat noisette de mai puis le court
avec des petits légumes fromage bûche
est engagé le tout arrosé de vins bio en
ligne